[Applause]
yep you're watching mailing it
in welcome to mailing it in look at all
those boxes none of them stolen gutter
snipe Joe asks were you bullied in
school and if you were is there one
Nemesis you'd like to thank today for
their harassment that led to your
success
cat yeah I was actually bullied a lot in
school and now I'm bullied
professionally
would you like
this I can have all of you thr actually
see he was actually he's doing it to you
guys now
see taught me how to do it for a living
thank God HR doesn't
watch this would go in my
file what do you think Vitz what you
were you bullied yes there was a group
of uh women that wore black all the time
they were called nuns and
um yeah they did
uh did a pretty good job on me with
pointers and yard sticks and uh they
left an impact did they ever hit your
hand when you were trying to cursive
right they would do this thing with a
ruler in my school like they hit
everything they hit everything and then
we had these Franciscan friars that had
ropes with knots yeah that they would
hit us with the knots on the I'm like
what is this school yeah and and the
weird thing is I learned to really enjoy
it yeah and now I'm in a club
[Laughter]
Joe it must have been a rough
childhood but there's got to be somebody
you can go thank you I can dish it out
too Greg I bet were you the bully well
one time a bully beat me up just cuz I
tried to take his lunch money uh but it
was my mom who taught me about bully she
said they only bully you because they're
jealous of how smart you are and how
good your family is so uh when they were
bullying me I said oh I'm sorry your
family sucks and you're an
[Laughter]
idiot Emily growing up were you ever a
victim of Mean Girls no no but you when
I but I do remember when
I I'm like no but but um when I was
little I remember there were these boys
that would tease me endlessly and tease
my sisters too and I you know but it's
the ' 80s they like tease you if they
like you or whatever but they they made
us miserable miserable and I remember we
were like prayed every day like please
let them move please let them move and
then one day they actually did it was
two brothers and the older brother
teased my sister and the younger one
teased me and you know how it is when
you're like seven or eight or whatever
we were and every day you're just
miserable like please stop please it was
like it was hideous I didn't have that
problem they dead just
but we have a surprise for you Emily you
know who's here
tonight bring him out
I'm I'm kidding I'm kidding they both
they both passed away in a fiery traffic
accident Matt back asks who do you think
is the greatest entertainer in your
lifetime and to save some time you don't
say
me Joe oh boy that's a tough question
greatest entertainer in my lifetime oh
that's got to be uh oh man uh
I can't does it rhyme with scharit I
can't say no Bill Cosby got cancelled so
I see him uh how about uh Jerry no I'm G
to go with nor McDonald he's my favorite
comedian the well late nor McDonald uh
uh always made me laugh inspire me to
get into this business I'd probably be a
pro boxer if it weren't for
him Emily prince prince and George
Michael and and prince who Harry
there's only one Prince that is true
that is true rip P Vince I got to go
Michael Jackson um yeah great it
objectively is Michael Jackson yeah he
he changed everything including the way
you look at
[Laughter]
kids really
what wait to hold on hold on he he
actually did not change that for
me I can't believe it was two soon for
that no cat would you like to go along
with Michael Jackson yeah he is you said
performer not like guy at being a dude
so at performing you have to
Michael she's like trying to think of
who who I would choose uh I would going
to go with Don Rickles good one good one
old school Don Rickles Chang the
world now he wouldn't probably get a gig
anywhere well cuz he's well he's dead
wow everybody we said is dead
H that's a
beat all right coming up you won't get
the blues with our local
news hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else